and as i'm speaking we are also going
live on youtube so if anybody is
interested
in watching this on youtube you can also
do that
i'll post the link right now in the chat
hey i had to stop sharing my screen
because i was just posting the link in
the chat box okay
so now we are good to go and
get started so i'll go ahead and share
my screen again
and i hope that everybody is able to
hear me clearly
as well as see my screen
you can just put in and yes in the chat
box if you have
if you're able to see and hear me
clearly and if you have any questions
again please keep on posting them
thank you
great so we are ready to begin here
thank you all for joining again today
welcome
to the first session of bioinformatics
for precision oncology
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand
diagnose and treat cancer the
transformation is driven by
high throughput molecular data from
patients
animal models and large scale cell line
experiments in this program we will
explore
how high throughput data can be analyzed
to study the genomic background of
cancer
of mixed data that describes the basic
biology
associated with cancer onset development
and outcomes and see how large-scale
data sets collected from
clinical trials provide an opportunity
to better understand this condition and
improve the precision
of clinical oncology my name is beepsha
biswas
and i am the omix logic community
manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
who are part of a bioinformatics
community managed by buying biotech
for those of you joining us for the
first time
i wanted to share about the omixlogic
programs
that are a result of a close
collaboration between buying biotech
and innovative big data analytics
company based in the us
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result the omics
logic programs have been
thoroughly tested around the world and
are known
to lead to excellent outcomes for
students with minimal bioinformatics
background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science
and biomedical research omits logic
is an international program that is
running in
five different regions with over 10
000 users around the world due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine
local program logistics and leverage
our online training resources adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers
around the world the goal of the omics
logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentor
and peer example developing a growing
community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation
of citizen science enabling students
clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology
in life and data sciences we will
combine
online sessions like today self-guided
study materials
and practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective
in our well-known and respected omics
logic programs
the program will contain online sessions
courses
on the basics of various type of data
like
genomics transcriptomics etc
as well as project data sets that come
from high
impact publications on various aspects
of cancer biology
so the first platform that i would want
you all to get
started with is learn.ormixlogic
so the platform is learn.omicslogic.com
i'm posting the link to the platform in
the chat box
this platform comes with a variety of
resources
so let us go ahead and check what this
platform is about
so let me go ahead and show you
so this is the learn platform and i'll
post the link again
in the chat box so that you all can go
ahead with me
and start with this platform so you'll
find that there is a login option here
and once you click on the login option
it will take you to the sign up page
and here you have the option to create
an account
either with your own email id so i'm
already logged in
or you can also use any of the social
logins
so once you are logged into the platform
you would be directly
going to the courses now
we have added all of the courses here
into different lessons so if any of you
were already familiar with the edu
platform
then we had courses divided as
introduction to genomics genomics one
and two what we have done with the learn
platform
is added to the introductory courses but
also added all the several different
stages of the courses into different
lessons so you can start with
just lesson one and progress so all
participants will have full access to
the platform and to all of the courses
so any of the courses marked with a star
that you see here
are premium courses and can be accessed
either as part of the program
or via a license which we are going to
be talking about
at the very end so there are a lot of
free resources
as well for everybody to get started
with so please feel free to explore this
platform
and we do not only have courses we also
have projects like these
as well as we have integrated coding in
r and python as part of this training
program
so without much ado and waiting for you
to
get started what i'm going to be
introducing you next to is the server
platform
so i hope that you are are logging
into learn.domexlogic so the server
platform is the next resource
that all of you will have access to as
part of the program
and we are going to be talking more
about how to utilize
this platform during this entire one
month training
and for our omixlogic participants to
reach out to us
i'm sorry about this one we have a slack
channel so this
channel is only open for all of our
participants
and the participants can actually go
ahead and join this group so we will
send out personal invites to all
participants this will just
make sure that you are able to connect
with our team
as part of this full one month training
so please make sure
that you are registered for the program
and you're receiving all of these emails
from our
end and there are also two other groups
that i would like to invite
all of the participants and everybody
who joins
any of our programs too so we have a
group on linkedin where you can connect
with
other members from all around the world
they are clinicians faculty
students also administrators so please
feel free to join any of these groups
and also
a group we have is on facebook so
you can find us on either of these
social media channels
and follow us there now let me go back
to the presentation quickly
and introduce you to our trainers
so we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified omix logic trainer and
expert by information she will guide the
hands-on sessions and assist
participants with projects and analysis
during the program
her area of specialization is in cancer
genomics and machine learning
dr mohit majumdar is our omits logic
project
mentor and an expert in big data
computational analysis he has a phd
in computational biology and over 10
years of experience working with
industry and academia elia brodsky
is the co-founder and ceo of fine
biotech
in his current role he has extensive
experience working together with
industry and academic partners who are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology and clinical applications
we also have clinton kona who is joining
us as one of the bioinformatics trainer
for this program
he has a master in bioinformatics from
the university of guelph
and a master's in cellular and molecular
medicine from the university of otawa
now i would like to invite dr mazumdar
to share more about the omits logic
precision
oncology program over to you dr mazumdar
thank you everyone
thank you deepsha and hello everyone
so just a second let me share my screen
hello everyone uh thank you for joining
this session and my name is mohit
mazumba
i have done my master's
in bioinformatics from jamia amelia
islamia and i did my phd and major
research work at jawala nehru university
india
and then after finishing my phd i was
able to work with
uh with a bioinformatics company helping
pharmaceutical companies to work who are
working on different bioinformatics
challenges
related to big data and applying machine
learning and data science
applications of data science in research
so in my car in the in this current role
in my control i'm working with
universities and i'm working with
students and research interns
to be able to work on several of
bioinformatics research
problems that we are seeing and also i'm
contributing in data science related
curriculums and
biological research of at different
levels of education
so talking about the session today and
about the program and the context of
this program
so one of the major objective of the
somix logic program is to be able to
learn from the asynchronous materials
different and the application of
different omics technology
and also learn from the example projects
however omixlogic oncology research
program
uh the one that we have designed is
helps
researchers and participants to not just
learn from the examples and learn about
the different omics technology but to
also explore
the hugely available public data on
ngs cancer research uh but
however i mean often times it's it's
kind of flick really hard
we find it like really hard to find the
right kind of omics data
for maybe precision oncology research
project
so uh learning about the impact of
ngs and the explosive growth of publicly
available data
one just wonder like you just have to
wonder about that
how much data is available and where you
can find the
rna data sets on cancer and you know
start
exploring what kind of experiments are
uh have done
uh to answer some of the important
questions that
sort of data is which is being utilized
by the pharma industry and
uh and the healthcare sector so we kind
of have compiled an um
post here where you can find uh
where you can find a good data sets and
work on and look at the available
resources
that are that have generated on also the
scientists who have generated and the
research labs who have generated
these data sets so during this time
interacting with many students
during our like omics logic educational
programs we realized that
the need for high quality data sources
that anyone can learn from
and use so defining good data so good
data is the data from
collections that follow a certain level
of metadata annotation
with minimal restrictions and easy
access to the files
so for example details of phenotypic
information associated with samples
as well as the file size or sequencing
instruments that are being used
those are all important factors so
another criteria would be
the number of replicates where they have
whether they are technical or biological
so some of the best repositories that
answers these
questions and like have those samples
are compiled in this blog post
so i'll just let me share this link with
all of you
so that you can visit this blog post
there you go so as i was telling you
that working on
example data sets so some of the example
data sets that are already available and
um
and we will be talking about those uh
those
projects is uh like modeling precision
medicine
so working on cell line data sets
and then working on example data sets
followed by
some of uh the other repositories like
uh
in one of the upcoming workshops that
will be happening in april
in collaboration with all india
institute of medical sciences will be
working on tcga
lymphoma data and uh and then going
through
the the publicly available data
specialized
for a department of pathology who are
working on
patient samples related to that so some
of the applications
can be directly you know you can find
directly on publicly available data
which will be utilized in this
in this program so we will be
really uh really happy to uh for you to
explore these data sets and come up with
your own research questions and we'll be
happy to
uh work with you on your research
problem uh
problems throughout this program
so with this information uh i'd like to
pass it on to
clinton uh who is here and will be one
of the omex logic trainers
helping us learn about the different
aspects of oncology research
so over to you clinton thank you dr
muzindor let me share my screen
all right
so precision medicine is changing
the way we understand diagnose and treat
cancer
this transformation is driven by high
throughput molecular data from patients
animal models
and large-scale cell line experiments
today we will introduce you to the
bioinformatics um for precision oncology
program
but before we do that let me share a few
points about my background
and the reason why bioinformatics is
central to the trans
to translational research in oncology my
name is clinton kuna
i completed my bachelor's degree at
carnegie mellon university
where i discovered my passion for
research later on
i decided to continue learning about
life sciences
as a result i now have two master's
degrees one from the university of
guelph
and the other from the university of
ottawa since i was interested in
translational bioinformatics
i did a masters in bioinformatics
and another one in molecular medicine as
a result
i am familiar with biomedical research
as well as
data analytics
so cancer is an extremely heterogeneous
disease
even though the war on cancer was
announced 70 years ago
that was announced 70 years ago brought
upon many advances in our understanding
of the basic mechanisms of tumor growth
and metastasis
it is also clear that the current
research did not solve the problem
on the contrary we are learning more and
more about this complex condition
to show how complex cancer is let me
give you an example
from my past research experience there
are several proteins that play different
roles within certain contexts
for example c20 like kinase or
slk is a protein that plays an important
role in cellular processes
such as proliferation migration and
apoptosis
it affects embryo development and is
shown to play a role in tumor genesis
this was studied in a new
induced mammary tumor model within mice
these experiments showed that slk
knockout mice
developed tumors faster and showed an
increased expression
of sox10 an important biomarker in
cancer
however in my own research we studied
slk in mouse embryonic fibroblasts
where slk knockout reduces focal
adhesion turnover
it turns out that slk plays different
roles depending on the context
even though this contradicts the other
study
it also shows how complex the biology of
cancer can be
and how careful we have to be with
experimental design
and data analysis to truly understand
its pathogenesis research on
is ongoing this is similar to cancer
every cancer is different and it's a
challenge to determine
where whether those where those
differences exist
we need more advanced methods to
determine why a knockout reduces a
process in one context but increases it
in another
my master's thesis gave me a glimpse of
how bioinformatics can be used to study
oncology
and the skills i acquired enabled me to
use more sophisticated models
and methods of analysis such as machine
learning
therefore based on my first masters i
decided to pursue
a masters in bioinformatics to learn
those complex skills
pure biology is good but having the data
analysis skills
to create meaningful relationships
definitely solves major problems
that can be translated into applications
within medicine
bioinformatics has exposed me to other
fields due to its interdisciplinary
nature
such as statistics engineering and
mathematics
so now let me pass it on to dr harpreet
to talk more about her research and her
experiences
thank you clinton let me share my screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
and i have a phd
in bioinformatics i have done my
doctoral from
csir institute of microbial technology
india and
jnu new delhi let me give you some
glimpse
how bioinformatics can be helpful in
identifying biomarker
or signature for a specific malignancy
by taking some examples from my research
work
my phd research was on biomarker
discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of the liver
cancer
using bioinformatics
so for the first part of this project
we used last scale transcriptomics data
to identify
a diagnostic biomarker panel for the
hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy
here we employed 30 dataset containing
nearly 4000 sample
to elucidate transcriptomic signature
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
particularly hepatocellular carcinoma
using
various bioinformatics techniques in the
second part
we employed nine data set containing
nearly 350 cleansio carcinoma
edison non-tumorous and 90
hepatocellular carcinoma
samples so here we scrutinize
a three-gene based signature which is
specific to the chlangiocarcinoma
implementing various data mining
techniques like
random forest svm extra tree logistic
regression etc
in the next part of the our project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data
of the hepatocellular carcinoma pacing
to identify
early and the late stage basis so
here we use tcga data of 350
scc samples and elucidate 51 features
that include 30 rna transcripts and 20
methylation cpg site
to discriminate early in the late stage
of some late stage samples of scc
so in my current role i am a mixed logic
bioinformatics trainer with pan biotech
i am assisting participants to learn
about data analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application of large data set
used in the biomedical research besides
i am involved in different uh in
designing different research projects
using publicly available data so to
provide
hands-on training and to make
participants familiar
with the approach to design and complete
our research project
we are continuously designing different
research projects
based on publicly available data
which are published in well-known
journals
thus we have a collection of research
projects where you can learn
how bioinformatics can be applied in the
field of oncology
using these freely available datasets to
drive biological
and clinical important biomarker for a
specific cancer conditions
so let me give you a glimpse of one
project where we focused on identifying
molecular signatures that are associated
with the clinical factors of the liver
cancer patients
based on integration of multi-omics data
here we explore different omics layers
that is
rna mi rna and clinical and demographic
characteristics
uh characteristics of the scc patients
to find out what are important molecular
signature that are associated with those
clinical phenotypes
like tumor stage risk factor ease gender
etc
so there are a number of the research
fellows who have completed their
research project in the field of
oncology
with pine biotech research fellowship
program
one of our research fellow miss semaya
dollar a undergraduate student from
turkey recently completed her research
project entitled long non-coding rna as
therapeutic target
in cll that is chronic lymphocytic
leukemia
using publicly available data and
implementing various tools
that are available on t1 for server
then ms ursha parikh who is postgraduate
student from india
completed her research project in
identifying
identification of biomarker to
differentiate between neural stem cell
and glioblastoma step stem cell using
various
tools on tbi info server and implying
data set take off taken from the public
repository
next mr kalamari maril who is a phd
student
from city in mexico he's he has
completed his research project entitled
classification of triple negative breast
cancer cell line
by gene expression analysis of
transmembrane protein using machine
learning algorithm
based on available cell line data and
using
different tools from our various
platforms
i am looking forward of to being your
mentor in the upcoming omics logic
pre-season oncology program now i would
like pass this session to ilia so over
to you ilya
thank you dr harpreed and everyone else
that
had a chance already to present and
i want to pick up on where
all of this kind of leads us to which is
the program itself
so up until now you've seen how to gain
access to the different resources
to see where you might see yourself
after you complete this program with an
independent project
or a better understanding of how
bioinformatics could be applied to
oncology research
and also some examples of real data sets
that you can have
access to as curated data sets or
then potentially a project of your own
where you have to identify
a new data set to do your own research
so what i want to speak to you today
about is the subject
of today's session which is the
introduction to this program
but before i do let me introduce myself
my name is elia brodsky
and i've had the privilege of running
hundreds of online and on-site programs
related to bioinformatics
and we've done this with our
collaborators at universities such as
georgetown university
louisiana state university tulane
university of haifa
and many others and so as a result
i've seen thousands of students from all
backgrounds complete their training
and get empowered by bioinformatics
tools to participate
in research studies develop data-driven
hypotheses for their projects and go on
to publish or present their projects in
poster review sessions
and so what i hope for all of you is
that this program will also help you in
your journey
whether you're only starting or have
already vast experience in oncology
so we hope that this program will be an
experience that will provide you with
new opportunities and skills
that will benefit you for years to come
so in this first session what we want to
do is kind of set the stage for
why we are learning about oncology and
what are specific
characteristics of cell and dna
and omics data that will be used in the
future sessions
so we'll talk about challenges
associated with big data and cancer
research
and then we'll talk about how next
generation sequencing data and other
types of high throughput data could be
used
to understand the biological processes
that lead to clinical manifestations of
cancer
so first let's talk about what is cancer
because
cancer is one of the leading causes of
morbidity and mortality worldwide
with almost 10 million people dying from
it per year
the cancer prevalence is the greatest in
the western world as you can see
on this map where you have close to six
percent of all people that have
cancer during their lifetime in the us
and worldwide there's an approximately
40 percent of men and women that will be
diagnosed with cancer at some point
during their lifetime
and in 2020 an estimated
17 000 children and adolescents
ages between 0 and 19 will be diagnosed
with cancer and ultimately
over 1700 young people will die
of this disease and so what we can see
from this data is that cancer risk
increases dramatically with age but
there are other
also causes of cancer that include
abnormal weight
use of tobacco exposure to radiation
as well as many different types of viral
infections
in fact about five percent of all
cancers are
caused by pathogens by viruses
so the bottom line is that cancer is a
genetic disease
and it is caused by cancer causing or
driving genetic changes inherited
mutations play
a role in about five to ten percent of
all cancers and the rest
are associated with somatic mutations
and changes
in the regulation of cell development
so when we study cancer we essentially
can think about this as a disease
of cells and we can observe the changes
of cells from being normal healthy
functioning
that's that are similar to other cells
in the tissue
to becoming abnormal or deregulated
cells
that start to form tumors or abnormal
growth
and metastasize or spread to the other
parts of the body
and so we can see how this process takes
time
and so there is exists an urgent need to
identify
new biomarkers or signatures in
biological processes that can help us
with early detection prognosis and
appropriate treatment selection and so
this is what this program is going to be
all about
so in this session which is called
introduction to oncology
we'll talk about some of the biological
changes in organs tissues and cells
what are some of the molecular factors
that are associated with tumor
development growth and metastasis
and how can we view the relationship
between
clinical diagnosis of this disease and
the molecular data
that essentially causes this disease to
appear
and has to be studied in controlled
experiments oftentimes
with an association of what we have
available for the clinical patient
level data and so this
uh part of it this part of the program
is essentially a fundamental
introduction that many of you are
probably already familiar with
but you will kind of have a refresh
of some of those terms that we will be
using throughout this course
and hopefully that will help us think
about the significance of the data
and the analysis methods that we will
continue to use
in the future sessions of this program
so since we talked about cells
one of the primary things that cells go
through
are individual cycles of cell division
and so cell division is essential for
normal growth
and normal kind of development of an
organism as well as
in our after we kind of grow up and we
mature as adults
cell division continues is a continuous
process and so it is essential
for life but it must be controlled and
so when a cell divides
it goes through several cycles that are
regulated
by a special family of proteins and it
controls the progression of a cell
through the cell cycle by activating
cyclin-dependent kinase
enzymes or groups of the enzymes are
required for synthesis of the cell cycle
and so when we talk about the cancer
cells
they are essentially cells that have
gone wrong
so they no longer respond to many of the
signals that control
cellular growth and death and cancer
cells
originate within tissues and as they
grow and divide they diverge
further and further from that normal
state and so over time these cells
become
increasingly resistant to the controls
that maintain normal tissue
so they divide more rapidly and their
progenitors
become less dependent on signals from
other cells so they become more and more
disconnected from the rest of the
organism and then
they evade programmed cell death despite
the fact that their multiple
abnormalities
would normally make them prime targets
for apoptosis
and in the late stages of cancer cells
break from normal tissue completely
they go outside of the boundary of that
tissue and eventually metastasize or
spread to new sides of the body
and so to help us think about this
process of cell deregulation
we can think of the different hallmark
features of cancer so as we said cancer
is
unchecked health growth mutations in
genes
can cause cancer by accelerating cell
division rates or inhibiting normal
controls on the system
such as cell cycle arrest or programmed
cell death
and as a mass of cancerous cell growth
it can develop into a tumor
and so when we think about these
hallmarks essentially
their original six hallmarks of cancer
one sustaining proliferative signaling
two evading growth suppressors three
activation of invasion and metastasis
four enabling replicative immortality
five inducing angiogenesis energetics
and six resisting cell death and so
in the recent time additional four
have been added such as deregulating
cellular energetics avoiding
immune destruction tumor promoting
inflammation
and genome instability and mutation
so here we observe the process
of a healthy cell that eventually
becomes
an invasive tumor and so we see this
as a complex condition that manifests in
changes
to cell regulation at many different
levels resulting in this abnormal growth
that we
call tumors these tumors consist of
cells
whose growth and morphological
characteristics are very different from
normal cells and so criteria for
malignancy
would include some of those features
that we just talked about like cell
proliferation
loss of differentiation infiltrative
growth and metastasis to other organs
that we associate with different stages
of cancer
and so here you can see how the cells
develop over time
and one of the primary objectives of
oncology
is to understand the mechanisms behind
such
processes that cause cancers
cancer cells to emerge and to grow
and so when 30 years ago scientists
could not even offer really a coherent
answer to this question about what is
the cause
of these changes and they just knew that
cancer arose from cells
that began to all of a sudden
proliferate uncontrollably within the
body
and they knew that chemicals radiation
and viruses could trigger this change
but exactly what happened nobody really
knew just 30 years ago
but over the last three decades an
emergence
of data about these cells has
revolutionized our understanding of
cancer
and this is because we have different
techniques now of molecular biology
as well as data science that allow us to
generate data
from the dna and the rna and the
proteins
in these individual cells tissues and
organs
and associate them with specific
molecular factors
at that could help us understand how
this process actually
evolves and so when we
see these cancer cells
we know that they are very different
right so for example how can we describe
this difference
one of the ways to describe them is
using phenotypic data or
phenotype and so we can look at their
morphology and how they look and kind of
try to categorize them for example they
have
large variably shaped nuclei they have
many dividing cells that are
disorganized and they're not
arranged in the same structure as a
tissue they have
a lot of different shapes and sizes and
they essentially
lose the normal features that we
associate with cells that have a
very defined structure and shape and so
as a result of
observing these phenotypic changes we
can start asking the question well how
is this phenotype as a result
of a disrupted production of cells
which is regulated at different levels
of dna
rna and signaling and so we can then
start to understand some of the basic
internal
cellular factors that contribute to the
development of cancers
but what we know today is that the
cancer cells
inside the tumor also leverage some of
the cells
in the tumor and around the tumor
and so we can think of this as a disease
that affects
the tumor cells as well as the tumor
micro
environment because cancer cells are
able to ignore signals that
normally tell cells to stop dividing
or that begin a process known as program
death or apoptosis and so
the body uses this process to get rid of
unneeded cells but because they stop
re responding to these signals they also
start affecting the cells around them
and so one of the things that we have to
study is
the cellular mechanisms the interaction
between cells
within a tumor that actually contain
many different cells
but then also to think about how they
interact with the rest of the tissue the
rest of the organ
and eventually what causes them to go
bit
beyond the tissue itself causing what's
called
invasion infiltration of other tissues
as well as metastases
now one of the other hallmarks that we
talked about was the evasion of the
immune response and so when we
think of cancer cells that stop
right stop uh responding to the
regulation within the cell
there are specific types of immune cells
that are supposed to recognize those
and attack them and so cancer cells
are known to evade this immune system
which is a network of organs tissues and
specialized cells that
protect the body from infections and
other conditions
and so normally the immune system would
remove damaged or
abnormal cells from the body but some
cancers are able to hide from the immune
system
and so there are two types of tumors hot
and cold tumors what are hot tumors hot
tumors
are those that show signs of
inflammation meaning the tumor has
already been infiltrated by
t cells rushing to fight the cancerous
cells so the tumor cells
have undergone many mutations that
create new antigens recognized by the t
cells so they can recognize them as
abnormal cells
now typically with the presence of
cancer fighting cells or t cells
we know that the immune system has
recognized them and is working to fight
and so for this reason hot tumors
typically respond well to immunotherapy
treatment
using checkpoint inhibitors because
those are present
and so the main idea behind checkpoint
inhibitors is to use
antibodies to mobilize even more t cell
response
during the attack on the tumor t cells
become exhausted
and lose important functions needed to
kill tumor cells
and so the exhaustion is brought on by
constant exposure to tumor antigens
and signaling through checkpoint
receptors the antibodies
block signaling through these receptors
to prevent this loss of function so
we'll look
at a project where we can observe this
loss of
function in these macrophages
what are the cold tumors some
non-immunogenic cold tumors
have not yet been infiltrated by t cells
and so this is a sign that the immune
system
is not working on one of for some reason
right so the lack of t cells
makes it difficult to provoke an immune
response with immunotherapy drugs
and so what we see at the cellular level
to the tissue level to the organ level
is that
these different characteristics of cells
at the molecular
and cellular level can help us diagnose
specific types of processes and try to
address them using
a number of innovative treatment options
so finally one of the main reasons
why cancer progresses to a late stage
and causes mortality
is because of metastasis and so
when cancer cells spread locally by
moving into near
normal tissue that's called invasion but
then they can
spread to nearby lymph nodes tissues or
other organs and so as a result we see
this
metastasis of cells in
the whole body and so when you observe
under a microscope
metastatic cancer cells have features
like the ones
that the primary cancer where they came
from and not like the cells
in the place where the cancer is found
so you can have for example
a metastatic cell come from the breast
and go into lungs and so that is
essentially a breast cell that is
causing cancer in the lung
and so what we see here is a number of
insights that could be very critical for
our ability to
treat cancers and recognize them
understanding
the reasons or the drivers of this
progression
okay so any questions so far about what
we have covered
if you have any questions we recommend
putting those
in the chat box so again if anyone has
any questions
about the process that we described here
at the biological level
if you have any questions about the
program itself you can use
the chat box to write those out
another resource that is important is
that we have
a slack channel for those that have
completed their registration to the
precision oncology program
so if you put any questions that you
would like us to address in our next
session
please add those to the slack channel
with a tag question
right so if we have a number of
questions for our next session
we'll be able to reflect on the material
that we've covered today
and continue on to speak about uh the
additional material
so what are we going to speak about
okay and so here we already have a
question describe more about checkpoint
inhibitors in immunotherapy
so great question now we have to speak
about
what are the methods that we have
to identify these specific changes
how signaling or the genetic regulation
of different types of expressed proteins
happens within the cell
so let me talk about that and section
if you are already a part of the program
please add your question
to the forum on slack and we will start
with that question in our next session
okay so when we speak about
the ways the methods to understand what
is going on
one of the things that we have one of
the technologies that
allows us to study these processes
at the subcellular level in other words
inside the cell
are techniques like next generation
sequencing so next generation sequencing
is essentially the process of taking
the genetic material from within the
cell of multiple cells within a tissue
extracting it and converting it to
digital data
so essentially we can survey what
exactly is happening at a given snapshot
in each cell and this could be done
using
a variety of what's called omics data
so omic data includes phenomics
genomics epigenomics and
transcriptomics and omix technologies
like next generation sequencing can be
used to explore the roles relationships
and
actions of the various types of
molecules that make up the cells of an
organism so for example here you can see
phenomx right so it's a collection of
automated
ways to categorize cells for example we
talked about
cell morphology right so this could
represent some kind of a phenotype
that we associate with a given cancer
cell genomics
or the data that represents the sequence
of the dna
genomic data represents either the
individual nucleotides
or the sequence rearrangements or the
variation in
segments like chromosome rearrangements
so when we talk about genomic data
we'll look at mutations copy number
variation
and rearrangement then we can talk about
epigenomics or the way that this data
in the dna could be silenced or made
more available for reading
using a variety of epigenetic regulation
mechanisms such as
small micrornas long non-coding rnas
and other types of methylation and
immunohis and sorry changes to
the chromatin right so we'll talk about
some of the role of the epigenomic data
that can reveal
those regulation patterns and mechanisms
and finally we have the ability to
measure
expression levels so we can ask the
question which
proteins essentially are going to be
produced
by looking at their proxy or the mrna so
we can
look at the whole spectrum of omix
technologies
using the sequencing technology of next
generation sequencing
and start asking questions what is
happening to the cell
what does that mean at the genomic level
how is it regulated
at the epigenomic level and what is the
result of that regulation on
what is being produced and so as a
result
what we want to do in this program is
take a
look at examples of basic and
translational oncology research projects
that will take
a look at single cell patient-derived
cell line projects
that will look at systems level
patient-derived
xenograft models and finally look at
real patient data where we can
get data from clinical trials and a
variety of translational projects that
will
help us understand the relationship
between comorbidities risk factors
individual people or patients
and how we can use all of that data
together for a variety of translational
applications
okay and i'll pause here just to answer
the question so
what are cell lines cell lines are
essentially cells taken from tumors of
individual patients
that are then immortalized
and could be grown in a lab instead of
in a body
they could be grown in a petri dish and
so you can see individual cells
that represent essentially what happens
in an organism to a certain degree
of what we can tell about a cell
so as we gain access to these different
data sets there's also a variety of
different challenges that
are arising from this availability of
data so as you can see here on the graph
uh starting from the uh you know 2010
approximately we have this dramatic
increase
in the availability of public data but
it comes with also
additional challenges one of the
challenges is that this data is very
variable
and very specific to individual projects
essentially that generator
it's also huge the data sets are fairly
large if you take
one next-generation sequencing data set
that might have between several to maybe
hundreds of samples you're talking about
gigabytes to terabytes of data
and so what's important about being able
to handle such data to process it
is that in this program we want to
introduce you to some resources
that will allow you to perform
computation of huge data sets
using cloud-based resources and
leverage them to essentially develop
structured data
out of these publicly available data
sets so how are we going to do that
in each case when we talk about genomics
epigenomics transcriptomics proteomics
we're talking about data sets that are
contained in
packages of short reads or
elements that have to be pieced together
to represent a structured data set that
we could actually analyze
and so one of the things that we will do
in this program is we will take this
raw data so what you can see here are
individual reads
mapped to a reference genome and so
we'll look at this raw data
to try to understand how we can detect
in this raw data
specific signal and that signal could be
variants so specific positions at the
dna level that have a mutation or a
change
we will look at the processing
quantification
and performing statistical analysis of
mrna expression data
including processing that data from raw
reads to a table of expression
and asking the question how can we
compare different conditions
to see changes within specific genes
and we'll also think about how do we
leverage big databases where we can use
annotation on gene ontology terms and
pathways
so that we can understand how this
information
the signal that we find in the data
could be turned into biologically
interpretable
information okay
okay and so we'll talk about the
schedule here in just a second thank you
sylvia for the question
but let me first show you how we can use
this resource for big data analysis
that will allow us to essentially study
such data
so please go with me to a link
server that t bio that
info and beep said if you could please
uh post the link as well as the demo
details
so this is a uh platform
a cloud-based platform for big data
analysis where you can analyze
large data sets from public repositories
like the ncbi
or tcga the cancer genome atlas
by uploading data directly from these
public
uh repositories or using data sets that
we'll be
uh providing you with these are curated
data sets that you can use
to perform analysis yourself and so the
first thing that we want to do
is look at one demo pipeline so this is
a pipeline
that will illustrate how the system
works
and you will see how logic of analysis
will be clear to you after just this one
exercise okay so please put number one
in the chat box if you have um
gotten to this platform and you see what
i see on the screen
okay so please put number one i'll just
give it a moment for everybody to get
here
okay thank you rich nish norman
musumi okay let's give it just another
minute for
a few more people to um get to this link
now once you get here you can log in
either using
account details that have been provided
to you by
email for those that have registered to
the program
and uh please make sure to add marketing
at pine bio to your
contact list because you will be
receiving emails about important account
information
uh after this session um or you can use
the demo account to log in
all right great so we have a few people
that are already here so
right now if you don't have an account
you can use the demo
so right here under transcriptomics you
want to click
on this arrow and let's go
to this first one demo rnaseq cell line
project so once you click on that link
you will see this pipeline this pipeline
combines a number of steps organized
into logical groups
by what you see in this frame like error
correction
exon detection mapping on genome etc
and now what we'll do is build a
pipeline so we'll essentially connect
the series of scripts together to
convert data from raw format
which is individual reads into a
structured format which is
a table of expression so first of all i
will click on start
and you can see how these logical steps
are organized
into a sequence first we do
pre-processing where
technical variation is removed from
individual read sequences
then we perform mapping where you align
those reads to the reference genome
and then we quantify the levels of
expression so we ask the question
how much of a given mrna is present
in the sample let's click on okay
as you can see i have a number of
options that are now highlighted
trimomatic bow tie 2g top hat 2
hysat2 and bow type 2t so based on the
logic that we just discussed
pre-processing mapping and
quantification
what do you think should be the next
step for me to take
which button should i click on next
remember it was
pre-processing mapping
and quantification which one should i
choose
pre-processing okay so which steps
specifically what does that button
say on it which button should i click on
so as you can see pre-processing we've
correctly identified it as a whole
okay great sakshan triumatic right it's
the only
one here so let's click on trimomatic
okay let's
learn about what does trimomatic
actually do how is it a pre-processing
step
so trimmermatic you can scroll down here
and it says trimmermatic algorithm
cleans technical sequences from a
database which stores sequences known to
be used as adapters in next-generation
sequencing experiments
from raw sequencing data so what is raw
sequencing data
individual reads and what sequences are
present there are specific
sequences that will align to
a database and we know that there are
going to be
technical sequences adapters and
sequences that essentially all of these
will be trimmed
right so we go through all of our
individual reads and trim
sequences that are not representative of
the true biological signal
in our data so this is traumatic so
after we
click on trimomatic we have another one
pop-up which is called pcr
clean which addresses the step of
this bridge amplification we'll talk a
lot more about this in our next session
and after we've done some pre-processing
we now have
mapping on transcripts so essentially
we're going to map those reads
onto a reference transcriptome
and then we will produce a level of
expression or quantification so we will
quantify
for each gene that we have in the human
genome for example we will give it an
expression level
and so using this rsm method
that will produce a table of expression
we can now click on end
and if you just wait a little bit you
will get here
some of the outputs from this pipeline
so please go ahead and explore this
pipeline
the outputs that we see here to
understand how
processing will help us produce
structured data
on thousands or hundreds or tens
of samples and thousands of genes
so this is something that we'll use in
the context of specific projects so you
probably saw that the project data set
that we have there
is called cell lines data and so
together with the cell lens data we have
a variety
of different projects as you can see
right here and we hope
that in the process of this program you
will also develop
a project of your own so learning from
these examples that are taken from
top peer-reviewed publications in
application to cancer
we'll see how you can develop a project
of your own
or potentially add on to what's already
in the data set that is described here
and so here we can see some of the
examples
at the level of predicting response
or outcome of for different cancers
discovering novel ideas and hypotheses
about the risk factors
and even potentially developing novel
intervention methods and so just to give
you a sense of how
this will be done here's an example of
one of those projects called
uh modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer
this is a data set from a publication
that was published in 2013
and it's interesting because here the
authors assembled a collection of
samples
with multi-omics data that could help
predict
drug response in another project
as you already heard dr harpridka or
describe
her experience with the cancer genome
atlas
we will go to the cancer genome atlas
which has samples from
thousands of patients across a variety
of tumor types
and we'll start asking the question
about specific
types of clinical information that we
have
and phenotypic information that we have
about those patients
and we'll go into the publication to
understand
what novel information has been
extracted from this collection of
patient data
associated with molecular data that can
help answer
questions about specific aspects of
hepatocellular carcinoma
like drivers of hypocellular carcinoma
different stages and biomarkers of
subtypes
as well as some of the response
different treatments
so what we'll do in this program is we
will talk about cancer biology
including the central dogma of molecular
biology the biological hallmarks of
cancer
the approaches to cancer diagnostic and
treatment selection
to the understanding of the biological
factors of the tumor itself
as well as its micro environment and
heterogeneity
and the regulation and targets in
specific biological pathways
that could provide the provide us with a
good understanding of biological factors
associated with this disease now we'll
also talk about
bioinformatics methods like processing
next generation sequencing data
variant calling the application of rna
seek analysis statistical analysis like
hypothesis testing and regression
machine learning including clustering
principle component analysis
and classification and annotation of
gene set enrichment
gene ontology terms and keg pathway
and then finally we'll introduce you in
detail two curated data sets from these
exampler projects and these include
projects from cell lines
the patient derives xenograft models of
tumor and stroma interaction where a
tumor is engrafted into an animal
mouse model the cancer genome atlas or
tcga
that will allow us to think about
clinical risk factors and outcomes
and also think about different types of
therapeutics for different
sub sub subtypes and stages of cancer
but we'll also talk about how to find
additional data on ncbi
and tcga and how to structure your
bioinformatics project
so now to answer sylvia's question and
to talk about
the program schedule and how to gain
access to all of these resources
i will pass it back on to beeps of
biswas to talk about
the program schedule
thank you elia for sharing this
wonderful
overview of what we are going to be
doing in the upcoming program
and now let me introduce you to the
omics logic resources that
we will utilize during this entire
training period
the program will leverage our top-rated
online tutorials using the
learn.omicslogic.com portal
with smart tracking activity and curated
data sets designed
for great learning experience
and throughout the course you will be
given directions to
access the tbi info platform for
bioinformatics processing
and analysis of rna-seq data
the platform will include demo pipelines
like we saw today as well as data
management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis will be
performed in different
sections of this multi-omics platform
and in this program we will be using
a research bioinformatics analysis to
help you develop
a logical understanding of key methods
involved in preparation of such data
and behind many of the methods are also
scripts written in popular coding
languages such as
r and python these are also explained in
tutorials you will have access to in
form of the code omics logic platform
from visualization of genomic data to
exploratory analysis and hypothesis
testing
and if you have not checked out the
precision oncology link here is a
snapshot of
all the sessions that we will cover so
to answer
silvia's question we are going to be
having
sessions on monday wednesday and friday
at the same time which is 10 a.m cst
and if you are looking forward to join
the program this is the link so let me
take you back to the website again
and show you how you can join this
program so this is the link
to join the program i will be sharing
the link in the chat box if you have not
yet registered for the program the
registration is still open
and you can go ahead and see what the
program is about we have also
added the different dates and the
session topics here so you can actually
see
what is the next session that we are
going to be having
and to register for the program uh once
you click on get started i'll go there
again
you will find there are three different
licenses
so as we are beginning i'll just again
explain what these three licenses
are the beginner license gives you
access to
all of these resources that we discussed
today
and the sessions as well as the slack
channel
and the project resources while the
intermediate license
gives you an access to a mentor who you
can meet one-on-one
every week to discuss any questions that
you may have
or to discuss your project while the
advanced license gives you
an additional 50 uh 30 days sorry not 15
days
additional 30 days to work on your
project
with our team of research fellows as
well as collaborate with any participant
so as you know that the program is
ending on 9th of april
and we will give everybody an extension
till april 16th
post that from april 16th to may 16th
anybody with an advanced license can
actually go ahead and work on their
project so they will
continue with their access to the
resources
as well as the program so i hope that
this would be clear for everybody so let
me go back
to the presentation i hope that you have
been able to review
all the different dates for the session
as well
and now i would like to invite clinton
to talk a little bit more about what is
the outcome
that every participant will have after
they complete this training so clinton
over to you
thank you vipsha
so as seen
in some of the earlier presentations
we will learn important concepts within
cancer biology such as the central dogma
the hallmarks how cancer is diagnosed
and treated
we will talk about several
bioinformatics methods
such as processing variant calling
rna-seq and more
finally we will look at sample projects
to learn how to make your own projects
by learning these concepts you will
you will be well structured to start
your own projects for
future analysis
so the learning outcomes is as follows
you will learn to read and understand
bioinformatics literature
perform basic ngs analysis
form hypotheses related to
bioinformatics
questions prepare data for machine
learning
cross-check actual signals or actual
data with other gene databases
know what type of data is required to
answer those scientific questions
create your own bioinformatic analyses
slash pipelines
present your and finally present your
results
in an organized way all all these skills
are essential in bioinformatics
and some can be translated to other
fields
after achieving the learning outcomes
you will
you would have learned some of the major
best practices
in the field of bioinformatics you will
be exposed to r
and python two powerful programming
languages
bioinformaticians will need to
understand how to use
t-test regression and other tests
analyzing and managing data you will
also learn how to
analyze and manage data in order to
communicate
important information to other
individuals
pipeline development and utilization is
another
common best practice within the field of
bioinformatics
ultimately completing the precision
oncology program
will help you enter the field of
bioinformatics
since you learn you will learn several
best practices
so now i would like to pass it back to
beep shop shot
to talk more about the registration and
form
thank you so much clinton and the chat
box is now open for any questions and
while
we are doing this i would want to know
more about
everybody who is present here in today's
meeting
so now you'll find a poll on your screen
i hope everybody can see the poll and
there are a few questions that we have
for you the first question is
what is your current country of
residence
and if you are from any of the other
countries which are not
listed around here you can also post
them in the chat box
the second question is what is your
current level of education
again if these levels of education are
not mentioned
you can also mention the others right in
the chat box
what is your area of interest or
specialization
again you can also write about any other
area of specialization
which is not pertaining to oncology
and the fourth question that we have is
what are your objectives in learning
about precision oncology
so there are few uh
uh topics to choose from if you are a
beginner and you have an interest in
cancer research
so you would want to learn more about
precision oncology you already work
on cancer research and want to implement
biofuel matrix to your research
you find the topic interesting or you're
not interested in oncology at
all so you have all of these options to
please
go ahead and
i'll keep this on for one more minute
and then i'll go back to the
presentation
and meanwhile as you are going forward
with the poll
please make sure that you also post
yeah you also post the questions in the
session yes and i think david
uh i'm sure i'm getting your name
correct so we did have the introduction
to oncology at the session
uh did you join in early i did not see
your message and as you're joining me if
you're participating in the session
what would be great is for us to know
more about who you are so if you can
always have your full name on
that would be really really helpful
okay so i will be ending the
poll right now that you see on the
screen
and next again what we would want
everybody to start with
is sign up to learn dot omics logic to
get started
and you know we have already spoken
about the slack platform that every
participant
will have access to who have joined this
training so you can post any of the
questions
that you have regarding the session
right there
as well as we have our linkedin page
and our facebook group that you can also
post in
and once you complete the training we
will also give you
a certificate like this and these are
some of the details regarding the
training program
and we have already gone through this
one so please feel free to check out the
link
on how to join this training
so in our previous program we have seen
participants have completed the training
successfully like olga udatseva here
who is a post-doctoral research fellow
at
roswell park cancer center and used her
experience
to learn about data analysis techniques
which she is now
applying in her own pre-clinical
research
and like olga there have been several
other participants who have
taken part in different omics logic
programs that we
offer and have been very successful at
them
and once you complete the program
you will receive a certificate of
participation that you can
use on your resume or link to your
profile
that shows all of your achievements
and this is why our previous program
participants like mikhail here ran the
omixlogic programs as a talk based on
program interactivity
personal feedback support and a quality
of projects you will be able to achieve
leveraging the resources we make
available and
mikhail has shared this very interesting
review
so i will again go back and share this
review with everyone here
so that you all can also take a look at
what he has to say about
and the omex logic programs right now
and while we are here please make sure
that if you are
joining the program again this is the
link to join
and we just want to mention that we also
offer
scholarships for students who require
them
so if you are someone who is interested
in applying for a scholarship so please
go to this link right here
and you can apply for the scholarship so
once you apply
and fill up the form right here you
would receive an email from our
end where we would ask you to set up a
meeting with
one of your references so based upon
that meeting just decided whether you
are going to receive the scholarship or
not
but please feel free to go ahead and
fill out this form right here if you are
interested
in applying
and i do hope that you
have if you have any questions you'll be
posting them
in the chat box so in the upcoming
session
we will discuss the types of information
that can be extracted from next
generation sequencing data
and you will learn about how to process
analyze and interpret genomic data
through specific pipelines
example techniques will include variant
calling mapping and finding the
significance of specific mutations
these are the common techniques used in
hospitals to analyze sequencing data
from cancer patients
in hopes to diagnose and potentially
design
an effective treatment plan
with this skill set and a few project
worth of experience you could also
be potentially on the path to help a
hospital near you or become a
bioinformatician who works
on cancer research so now the session is
again
open for any questions that you may have
please feel free to ask us
any questions okay and you can also see
the polled results right now
on your screen so i see that
we have about eight percent of people
who are from the us
23 from mexico and eight percent again
from peru
we also have a large number of
participants today who are not from
us so we also have here in the chat
nigeria
iraq and bangladesh
what is your current level of education
so most of the participants here hold
a bachelor degree or are in the
undergraduate program
while 23 percent are in master's degree
15 percent in phd
while 15 percent are also faculty
while there are others who also are
compromising of 15 percent
and area of interest or specialization
so 54 percent present here
are of course well into
precision oncology or oncology as a
whole while 23 percent are interested in
biofuel matrix
the rest are undecided or interested in
something else
you can also write about those interests
right down in the chat box
what are your objectives and learning
about decision oncology
so you are a beginner and your interest
is in cancer research
69 percent have said that they are a
beginner
i work on cancer and want to implement
biofuel matrix
so that is comprising of 31 percent
while we do not have anyone else for the
rest of the
fields listed there so thank you all for
sharing again
again if you have any question we will
let you know so
i are you already registered for the
program so this was the only free
session that we have as part of the
bioinformatics for precision oncology
program for the upcoming one month
program you would have to register for
the full program to gain access to those
sessions all
participants will receive an email and
the sessions please note this the
sessions will start
at 10 am cst so if you
have missed out or joined later please
review the video that we will be
emailing you and sending it to you and
we will also share those videos
in the slack channel so that you are
able to review them
later as well
and if you have any other questions
please let us know
you